30 seconds did you ever think you would
make it I feel I'm so I tast Sweet
Victory I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giv values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no
[Music]
value's in the house okay so we have
Mike MAAC on the podcast here today if
you don't know him from the uh you may
recognize him by uh some of the folks
he's dated some of the podcasts he's
done impulsive podcast 5 million
subscribers with Logan Paul uh you you
may you may recognize him from a book uh
the fifth vital you sent me very
interesting story and uh you know I
think you and how do we get connected
the first time we got connected because
I had I told Logan to take a 90-day
break take a break take a break Logan
Paul I think what you need to do is you
need to take a break yeah that one I
don't know why that was so controversial
in the camp yeah like it's looking back
I just watched that video tonight I did
a bunch of you know research on the way
in here and I watched that and you were
the same person that I've come to know
you as well spoken researched you
brought up examples from your own past
how you hired your PR team you didn't
like what PR team stood for because they
told you what to say and it it's now
watching it seemed very well thought out
but yeah I don't how did we how did we
get connected in the wake of that
through was it through George
potentially I'm trying to see because we
spoke that day for uh we got on a oh you
know what it was it was that and then
there was also a fallen out that was
taking place what we reacted to I think
there's a fallen out going there maybe
there's something going on with George
and Logan and was it was it not at first
nobody really knew if it was for real or
not yeah but by the way before we get
into this very important to show this R
because can you pull this up CNN
breaking news literally right now okay
Biden's response to Jordan back is
likely to be powerful but us is wary of
triggering a wider war with Iran
official say which which we'll react to
this later on maybe we'll talk a little
bit of in McMahon we'll talk a little
bit of California I saw your Tweet about
California I want to see what you're
going to say about that we'll talk some
jenko we'll talk some Logan Paul we got
a lot of things to talk about but why
don't we start off with this so what I
don't know a lot about Mike is the
following I I started social media late
okay I've never downloaded Vine I was
never on Vine I got on everything super
late right and and I'm I think I'm s
years older than you I think we're you
just had a birthday happy birthday 39 I
got one more that's right the last one
more year bro one more year it's over
it's over back so tell us like the the
history of yourself maybe I don't know
how far you guys go back you Logan jenko
H how did all these relationships and
friendships get started it's like a
that's like a multi heed question that's
like a going back in time dude going
back through the the the Old Testament
uh first of all I want to say
this we've been trying to get the show
done for a while your your your team's
been great I've been trying to to make
the dates line up I am I am honored to
be on the show you are you are as I said
extremely well spoken extremely well
researched uh willing to talk about
topics all you guys by the way that are
considered to be uh you know um taboo or
or you know outside the box and I've
I've I I've told you this before on the
phone directly before coming on the show
and and you know hu huge fan of what you
guys are doing and to be completely
honest even after
420 episodes of impulsive sitting down
with Arnold Gees and Egger and and Kevin
Hart and um you know a lot of really big
names even you know semi- debating
Shapiro on the show I get nervous to do
these shows I still do I my ner I get
very tense uh being around guys that are
are well studied well researched and and
being on someone else's home turf and I
made a decision at the end of uh Midway
through 2023 after saying no to a lot of
big podcasts I mean be you know up front
right off the bat you know Tate has
asked me to come out to Romania and you
know I'll say oh the state of the world
is bad right now or you know different
Comedians and I I I for 2024 I wanted to
force myself to get outside of my
comfort zone and to and to take some
chances and um you know I walked in here
you guys are are awesome you
know what I'm saying it already feels
like I'm hanging out with a bunch of my
friends so which is great but um I just
want to get that out of the way and say
thank you for having well I appreciate
that yeah and by the way to to say to
you I think I even commented on that
video uh saying y your perspective on
how you you know give your feedback is
also thought out I mean you're very good
communicator when I watch that show and
sometimes you jump in and you give your
thoughts it's very obvious you're a
talented Logan wouldn't have you be his
co-host or you know as a partner unless
if he thought there was value that's
being brought up both ways and I think
it's worked out very well between the
two of you guys you know he was always
getting back to your question he was
always uh meant to be this this oneman
Superstar which which he's finally kind
of like reached his final evolution into
now with WWE and this this character
that he now plays that you know just
obviously won the other night Royal
Rumble retained his title um it w he was
always that guy and I was always the
networker that was my that was my goal
that was my job since day one coming in
building relationships this person that
person in fact doing my best to to to
squash beefs that might exist between
himself and KSI who he now has you know
a massive uh Beverage Company hydration
brand with um that was kind of what what
I always brought to the to the table was
networking it's probably the thing that
I'm best at in life it's just ability to
build rapport with people quickly make
them feel comfortable um and just build
those friendships pretty quickly um I
was working actually on the brand side
when I met Logan I was at a company
called L saac that sold these oversized
I had one this guy went on a rant about
how much he loves love saac I would jump
off my balcony and fall on this scene to
show people how sick these things were
they're phenomenal they're amazing yeah
and there's no there's no beans it's
like a a shredded durofoam but basically
uh this guy Sean Nelson started this
company and the thing skyrocketed and
and it and it went from these oversized
not H bean bag chairs into these modular
couches when I joined it was probably a
$ 58 million annual brand I joined very
obviously as you know very rough around
the edges coming off of just some really
nasty that I've been through in my
life uh just doing my best you know
faking it till I make it all the way the
whole entire way and just and just
applying whatever skills I had and uh
one day I got a uh an email from our our
agency our Ad Agency and they were like
oh I'm going to connect you with this
influencer Logan Paul this is like 2015
like influencer what the f what does
that mean so 2015 is nine years ago
Logan would be what he would be 20 20
years 20 21 something like that this
before he had a beard yeah bro when he
had the hair the S Justin Bieber keep
the beard bro you look good the wor like
the the worst days the worst days dude
oh no no it's a different human right by
the way this is like the Logan Paul that
a lot of people still resonate with like
there's a lot of people who still like
no matter what he does no matter what
rope he jumps off no matter what you
know company he starts no matter how
well he does in the podcast this will
always be the Logan Paul that a lot of
people know they they despise this
douchebag esque character right and this
is who I was this is who I was linked up
that's your boy right there yeah 2015
did you know who he was in so you have
no idea absolutely no idea I was I was
working at this brand had a had a great
job was making six figures had stock
ownership had you know all the benefits
for1 1K package everything and I I love
my life I was doing it you know uh doing
what I had come to you know kind of
understand and learn which was social
media pretty pretty quickly and I get
connected Logan he sends me this text
message that says like yo what's the
deal with these love sacks uh can you
on him like that's what he that's
what he asked me and I'm that's message
number one message number one that's and
I'm a marketing marketing manager at a
corporation that's currently going from
58 million to 200 million annual like
we're on on that path we're about to I'm
I'm I'm literally you know months away
or maybe a year or so away from ringing
the bell on NASDAQ which I did with them
and uh I don't know how to respond to
this am I supposed to respond as a cool
guy am I supposed to respond as a as a
corporate guy and I took a risk and I
said yeah they're great the covers are
machine washable so if you get come on
them it can wash right out and he
thought that that was the funniest thing
resp yeah just like a real you're
talking to a 19 20y old at time so so
back to the point of me being
Communicator Rapport Builder I said what
does this person want to like how do
they want this message delivered right
laundry laundry exactly so I I sent him
this and that then led us to to kind of
hitting it off you know starting this
this friendship which then led to a a
brand uh collaboration that we did at
Travis P's house um where we met for the
first time with Roman Atwood um in uh in
Maryland and uh and and it was just
immediate Rapport I mean it was we we we
you know built a friendship and and
slowly but surely he asked me more and
more to be a part of the content um
which I did and then in uh 20 so so late
2017 I was hanging out there more and
more in Los Angeles and then Tokyo
happened and that was obviously a
nuclear bomb were you there with him or
I was and I'd flown I'd flown back and
obviously he was on this massive
trajectory to this is the this is the
suicide so he was on this trajectory to
be the big the biggest thing ever
already in in a very different in social
media brand world was had a had a very
successful clothing brand I think did
$50 million in 2017 Revenue at 20 20 or
21 years old um and this happens and um
my phone is just blowing up I mean
hundreds of text message on on New
Year's Day and it that that whole
situation slowly led to me joining the
team in a business role which was
basically having another basically being
his big brother going out there and
being someone that's like like like
there was a lot of jokes about being
like a babysitter rle but um just
joining the business team he had a lot
of loose ends on the business side uh
legal that was taking too high of a
percentage from him uh you know a couple
people with their hands in the pot that
shouldn't have been there I cleaned a
lot of that stuff up worked with his
manager to clean a lot of that stuff up
and um that then led to us discussing
the idea of starting a podcast together
which we did in November 2018 and then
the rest is televised boom got it so and
then to that point when does George join
you guys George so George and Logan had
already been friends um prior to prior
to me and Logan becoming friends they
had been at, 1600 Vine Together they'
made a ton of videos together um they
were they were like best friends
basically uh already and so so when I
came into the picture like he was
already he was already there and and
then as far as the podcast is concerned
obviously we went through two co-hosts
Spencer and then Mack went through they
were on the show and you know we parted
ways for various reasons um we actually
just shot an episode with those two guys
last night so which was cool to bring
them back so we had all four of the the
original kind of co-host together and
then George came on uh uh notoriously or
historically uh on the uh 69ine episode
for 69 first episode after being locked
up after all that stuff went down had an
amazing episode the audience resonated
with him in a major way and with George
or with 69ine uh with George okay not
69ine nobody's going yeah that guy
although listen if you put 69ine in
front of a camera that guy gets eyeballs
people are so interested in in the way
he is that's not a good so so okay I
mean it's a business model for some but
so so George comes on he he lights up
with tekashi with the 69ine that goes
well and then is it kind of like hey
let's kind of bring him back one more
time or one more time and it becomes a
regular like slowly but surely he he
start he started being on more and more
EP episodes and that I remember uh Logan
wanted to uh extend uh Revenue share
basically what with him at one point
which which we did and he became a a
partner in the show basically got it
okay and then how long did that go with
George being on in the three of you he
was there do you have that episode
number for that that 69ine episode 215
two so he was there from 25 probably
until about
360 or 370 he was there for a long time
make no mistake George was
a a big part of the show he's a staple
of the show and and easily the biggest
uh three slot we've had um uh definitely
the audience favorite three slot we've
ever had potentially the audience
favorite in general to be honest with
you at at certain points at least um and
a loved him so much you know he um it's
weird I think I think George kind of um
prefaced a wave of uh conservatism
traditionality and religion that that he
he kind of predated a little bit I mean
if you go back back to the to the 69ine
episode that was well before there was a
red pill push that was well well before
Tate had really started to you know
explode um and and I mean yeah back in
in 2020 and so I think I think there was
already an appetite for that type of
traditionality mindset and that return
to conservatism and he was he was kind
of hitting that audience and um you
know I think I think as far as
viewpoints are concerned I'm in the
middle of of George and Logan and that's
not to say Logan's a a liberal but he's
he's the youngest of the three of us he
was raised in a in a uh not not his
household because his household would be
in Ohio would have been very
conservative but the way that he's been
he's grown up in front of the camera
he's been around a lot of you know
Showbiz Hollywood PR people as we
discussed earlier and I think that
potentially could have you know swayed
some of his his viewpoints uh to where
they were at that time because they're
really not there anymore I think I think
we've he has and I have both probably
moved a little bit over the past couple
years what what caused
that I think living I think living I
think um as they say you know uh the
youth votes left and and and as you as
you age up you start to yearn for that
conventionality and that and that
conservatism uh that that you that you
uh remember from and and are attached to
from the days of old right and you're
like damn it wasn't always like
thish it wasn't always like this and
young young kids want progression they
want how far can we take this thing dude
like well where can this go and as you
get older you're like damn man I
remember a day where where you know you
would you would see your neighbors out
and you would say what's up and you'd
spend time with them and and and the
family unit was protected and and you
know all the other things that we're
talking about now and so I think I think
George was was actually on the Forefront
of that a little bit and I think the
audience resonated with that so the
fallen out with with with George because
uh when I when I watched that first time
I'm like are these guys F like maybe and
I think it was like oh they're falling
forward even though you know pbd podcast
and another the podcast has fallen for
this there's not really and like maybe
maybe there's not really anything maybe
there like a little bit of a you know uh
what do you call it like a unscripted
drama right to kind of like and that I
mean obviously that's effective Kim
Kardashian build a whole brand uh
keeping up with Kardashians and who
knows what percentage of that is
effective so one time it's my birthday
and I'm sitting here doing a podcast
and then these guys decide it's a
phenomenal idea to start a fist fight
and fight each other I have no idea
what's going on so they start cursing
each other out you're full of I'm
raising their voices I'm like wait wait
wait what the hell is going on here this
lasted for about seven minutes by the
way right it's believable watch this
I'll punch you watch this I'll punch you
in your face right now step outside
right now hold me back Mike step outside
is this real I'll punch him in his face
so anyways and then it was your birthday
it was my bir like I had I was like you
know what I'll meet you outside I walked
out I got what's going on I came back in
with a cake oh that's nice don't mess
with him he's from New Britain bro from
Yonkers but I grew up in New Britain too
nobody is scared of Connecticut M oh oh
oh really yo now we're going to beat
your Mike together I'm going to be H
Connecticut guys he's
right you're from
Connecticut bro you're son's going back
to George so what what happened because
you're is it are you even involved in
this or is this like you're in the
middle and two friends who are going
prior to you they're going at it and
you're kind of trying to be the mediator
what did you see what involved to this
obviously I've seen some of it but how
did it get to the point of saying you're
fired you're out we're moving on um I
think you saw that I think you saw where
I was just by way of what was televised
I mean I I 100% was a was a bridge and
trying to be a mediator in the situation
um I think that there there was as I
mentioned earlier in in what George kind
of stands for that that is so uh
ingrained in his being it is so innate
and and real and authentic in him that
it is it is his life's purpose to push
the work of the Lord to uh push the
ideas of of um conservative conservatism
and traditionality and family unit and
and and monogamy um which is
incredible but but I think that I think
that that's not to say that those values
are not important to Logan or to me but
that's not necessarily what that show is
about if that makes sense it's it's an
entertainment podcast we have guests on
I I asked Rick Ross today before I came
here we had Rick Ross in the show we
were supposed to have Johnny Manzel on
as well today I asked Rick Ross um if he
was interested in being cryogenically
frozen which I would like to talk to you
guys about as well there's no there's
not you know we're not asking him like
you know when did you decide that this
person you know when did your
relationship with Jesus reach this point
that stuff's incredible and so important
and so impactful and the fact that
George has devoted his life to doing
that stuff is incredible but it it was
it was slightly disjointed from the more
um from the more jovial style of the
show and I think I think that that and
by the way this is just one part of it
it's pretty it's pretty complicated
scenario but I think that that kind of
um I think it really
uh uh messed with George even more
because he because he wants he want he
knows that he should be doing that stuff
talking about that stuff prioritizing
that stuff and the fact that this wasn't
a an environment that was conducive to
those type of conversations I think was
was an
unattractive uh situation for him let me
let me ask this question like because
you know for somebody that watches a
show or consumes a show you're kind of
like okay do those guys are there's an
element it fits
just working out our podcast there's
some days I do 101 great something like
that but there's our group that likes
home team podcast and it's just us
talking about evance views what's going
on current event this what about this
and we do business politics me Vinnie
Tom you know and Adam Adam and Tom and
you know Tom will take up that entire
space with notes and he'll literally
come and prepare hours you know it's
different so for the audience the
audience watches and and say you know
each person played the role okay maybe
you were the point guard maybe Logan's
the scorer he's a two but he's the guy
that's driving the eyeball so if he's
playing Michael you're playing point you
know whatever and he's playing third and
you know still it's a team that's
working out do you think do you think
the whole process could have been
handled in a different way for it to
either end or for it to continue because
based on what you're saying it's fair to
say look this is what we're talking
about George has a certain set of values
and principles that's so core to him
he's not going to change we can't change
him he can't change Us best bet is
here's what we're doing right we're
going to go part ways but do you think
there's a different way you guys could
have gone about wrapping up the
relationship in hindsight everything can
be done differently every there could be
a little tweak here there could be a
little tweak there um he had already
started his his own show which as you
all know is has become extremely
successful um and um
yeah I mean I mean there were
conversations that happened that were
that were in my eyes looking back they
could have been done a lot better there
were there were conversations that
involved religion there were
conversations that involved
um you know George's feelings and
George's sentiment towards uh how he was
being treated by guests that were on our
show um that were that potentially could
have been overlooked um I I'll just say
this for myself I I I really did from
the bottom of my heart try the hardest
that I possibly could to to to when I
saw things start to go off the rails um
a little bit from both sides to try to
steer it back on track um I mean you can
you can simply just watch the episodes
and you'll see me putting my hand up
like yo don't you know like this is
going too far like he's pissed off and
by the way he has a reason to be so like
I did that the whole time and did the
same thing behind the scenes um and so I
can only speak for myself I I'm I'm I'm
39 years old
um I've been through a lot of in my
life and I like to believe that the way
that I handle relationships the respect
that I have for people the empathy that
I have for people the care that I take
in every single interaction um that I
have in this world I feel fantastic
about the way that I did in in the
situation um I ran into George the other
day I know you probably weren't going to
say it because it was I'm not going to
say you could say I'm so I texted you
about it um obviously um it was the
first time I'd seen him since everything
had happened happened um I was on a
plane down here and I was sitting in my
seat and you know texting and I look up
and there he is what are the chances
there he is crazy getting on the on the
way to Miami on the way to Miami well
that's who's not coming to Miami this
time but but I tell you though it's not
listen there's a lot of people I've done
business with for the last 20 years and
I've not run ran into them at the
airport you know so it's it's pretty
random for I knew it was going to happen
yeah I it's it was serendipitous and I
knew it was going to happen he was with
um who who they just got engaged I'm
sure you know and incredible um and and
honestly super sweet girl I mean you can
tell they're in
love th they are both incredible people
George is George is an incredible person
he is he th those values I talked about
before those are not teachable values
those are ingrained in his soul and his
heart he is a beautiful human and Bell
is a is a is a um a perfect mesh for him
like like talk about a couple that I
knew that we all knew this was going to
happen and um and so I see him on the
plane with with bell and toe and uh and
you know I think he didn't really know
what to say and I I just I was just in
shock so I just did the only thing that
felt natural to me which was I stood up
and I put my hand
out you know and I just put my hand out
and he shook my hand and we smiled at
each other and it was it was like
nothing had ever happened and and
sometimes you have uh um dis agreement
sometimes you have falling out sometimes
you have business issues um by the way
like I haven't covered all the factors
some of it we still don't talk about
very publicly on on both sides um but
sometimes you have those issues with
people and the only cure and this is so
hard for a lot of people to hear when
they're in these scenarios is time
everybody wants things to be solved now
because it's uncomfortable for them
nobody wants to feel like someone's mad
at them I would hate to piss you off on
the show any of you guys I would leave
here and I'll be like damn it dude like
what can I do to fix this what can I do
to fix this and as you age and you you
gain wisdom and experience in how the
world works a lot of times you realize
that time is the only thing that's going
to fix something there's no solve that
can be taken right now so this flight
was from LA to Miami yeah yeah so that's
a 5 hour flight yeah okay I don't know
how far you guys were sitting from each
other well that was another complicated
situation so let me I what what I'm
suggesting is the fact that it's not
you're like I wasn't I wasn't 2B was in
2 Z but like you have five and a half
hours to think oh is this guy like
you didn't talk to him during the flight
after the flight you get out you're
you're checking luggage like walk us
like the story doesn't end hey saying hi
oh oh yeah okay so so so when George
flies he flies a group of people with
him his his his people because it's how
he is he FES with people
um I was I was in first class okay
that's my guy okay but but now George
can obviously afford to go in first
class but playing with a group of people
grp of people and he probably I don't
know maybe he can afford to do that
maybe he just doesn't want to any FES
economy but like talk about like a
shitty situation for me to like start
off the interaction like an like
we're having this quick conversation and
then like I'm like oh I got to sit back
down here and I don't know it just felt
like rich people rich people
kind of have like a like not rich people
but like people that are in a a
situation of class that is over someone
else you get looked at we like it's just
a weird scenario like I wish I was just
sitting somewhere near him and it would
have been a little bit I don't know it
just was weird okay to like be back
there and then to like say okay like
I'll be up here like eating these
mix
knots well listen uh I
know sometimes roasted nuts when we're
not flying private with pbd you know pbd
is in 1A Vinnie and I are sharing a seat
next to a fat person in 27 C and D oh we
sleep on shoulders so you know sometimes
they're flying private sometimes they're
flying Spirit you kind of can't get too
comfortable Mike although Spirits about
to go out of business yeah they are
because a judge denied them being bought
by JetBlue but that's a different story
oh yeah the murder right so I don't know
and what I was getting at with that is
it was just a weird dynamic and and see
he's like humble and flies with his crew
I'm like dude I'm 63 I need the
room my videographer is in the back
if I could put my girl in the back like
no
okay n but but okay so when when the
over so the flight so the flight land we
get off and we have this we have this
conversation and it it literally was
like nothing had changed I mean it was
yo congrat I just want to tell you guys
congratulations and and um he uh he's
got big plans for the show and and um
you know I told him dude congratulations
on the Tate shows like like dude you you
I said you have what I think a lot of
people consider to be one of the more
preeminent T interviews you know what
I'm saying the way that he was able to
humanize push back on them ask hard
questions I know you you also did
obviously a fantastic job with that with
that um beast of of an interview and um
you know he he he told me that he's just
in a in a better place now he's in a
better place mentally um he's excited
about the future because as we all
know uh when you are misaligned with
your purpose in life that brings along
problems it brings along anxiety it
brings along you know lack of confidence
it brings along a lot of things that I
think he was Mike one one quick followup
hypothetical let's say you're sitting
there you're on the flight and it's you
and Logan sitting on the flight First
Class 1 a 1B George walks in how had
that situation been
different Logan would have bought the
plane and kicked everybody off no so no
so EV no so
evidently hypothe everybody off correct
this is a hypothetical but Logan's
sitting there as well no no so evid not
you know evidently they're talking too
okay evidently there's their
conversations there too and they've been
and they've been you know exchanging
Christmas cards I will say I didn't get
a Christmas card from either of you guys
so they both got each other's christm
card so like you know like it is what it
is but uh but yeah like I I have a
feeling that um it's just one of those
situations in life that worked out the
way it worked out and everyone will be
better or at the very least different as
a result of it and everything happens
for a reason yeah I I like to believe so
so for me you know I I I watched The
Exchange you know where he's like you
know you says I need a you you said I
need a therapist uh instead of Jesus
because Jesus isn't doing it for me or
something like that and Lan's like no
that's not what I said here's what I
said so tell me why I need a therapist
because you know you need to upgrade
your life you know what do you mean by
that like you need to improve certain
what Parents emotional intelligence me
emotional and then going back and forth
and then eventually so of course you
you're you're against Gaye You're
against woman you're you your eff and
scumback that would Port take and
obviously it was fast emotions are high
when this is being said but for me when
I when I size everybody up when I size
you up and I size Logan up and I size
George up I don't know any one of you
meaning I've not broken bread with
anybody until that day George came here
and after he interviewed me at the Cigar
Lounge we had then afterwards I took him
to the house and then we were eat you
were there as well we were eating and he
was with it he was with his crew and his
girl yeah and then afterwards we hung
out you know we we were at the house and
all this stuff and jennif like a truck
guys's got to go to sleep now give him
the truck I take the truck are you
serious he need a car yeah so anyways so
so that was the experience with George
and we had him George George here with
uh uh marmar the Assyrian which was very
interesting different kind of an
approach conversation you know and then
uh he you know uh he wanted to get in in
contact with Tate I messaged Tate it's
like absolutely and I put them in
contact together I thought the guy
freaking was unbelievable by the way I
tell you I I said this a few podcasts
ago and I told him privately as well
this guy's this guy's not good this guy
this guy has the the legs to be really
really good in this space because he can
not only draw from a lot of different
things and he actually knows how to hold
himself together under pressure and
still ask the question and be fair it's
you know and the part about uh uh the
different Dynamics then I'll go to Logan
with Logan when I watch Logan I think
Logan is on a freaking what do you want
to call it on a jet you know rocket ship
I mean rocket ship is a better one to
start him you know attention he's
getting you know wrestling they're
obviously turning him into the next
Superstar whoever that's going to be is
it going to be the next Rock the next
this if he's constantly winning they're
building the next hero right into
whoever he's going to be a phenomenon in
that area and soon to be a billionaire
with his drink with KSI they're doing a
billion two billion year whatever
they're doing Prime is everywhere UFC um
and and when you're that young young
going at the pace that you're going
you're going to break a lot of things
and there's not really a full-blown
manual because one manual again when I'm
sizing him up I've never spoken to Logan
this is your friend you know I've never
spoken to him we've never had an
exchange but when you're going that
fast you got your manager you got your
PR you got all these people trying to
tell you what to do and then you're
trying to tell everybody to shut the let
me do what I want to do but then if I
say this and it's really what I say I
may lose this deal and lose that deal
and what about this and what about that
and there's this much money sitting on
the table and those guys told me be
careful this because you don't want to
piss those guys because they may buy
this there's so much noise it is so
noisy where he's at in here that there's
nobody that knows that but probably him
and guys that came before him so maybe
rock you know maybe a you know not that
many guys it's only going to be like 10
people that he can go to talk to that
are going to understand where he's at
now people having said that having said
that at the same time
uh when you're when you're a a God
fearing God loving man and you live your
life the way George is living you have
Grace and and Grace means you're going
to go God's going to bless you he's had
an incredible life and by the way the
job he did with the interview he's got
some 330,000 Subs in in a month his
YouTube channel there's guys that do
that for 10 years and they don't get to
30 he did 330 in a single month and you
know you know I know what it is to sit
on the back of a plane and go with a
crew of 10 people you try to save money
CU it's like instead of buying a flight,
1500 bucks and you're doing that we've
all been there before when you're doing
that but this guy's going to make a lot
of money uh uh God willing he's going to
be a great father he's going to be a
great husband he's going that route and
I think in in Logan's ear when you're by
yourself
alone again my opinion and I'm very
comfortable being wrong for the rest of
my life I'm very comfortable being wrong
it's very hard to find jenko in your
life as a friend dude it's so hard to
find a jenko because the guy literally
wants nothing from you you know what I'm
saying it's not like I'm trying to you
know and and the jenos we all need you
you know everybody in life there's
certain people like you find it you know
you know when we younger and we're
dating a girl and like that could have
been the one but you effed up you
screwed up we all got that right you
know you're younger you got a friend
you're like ah you know you had
like a mentor like oh dude that and then
eventually like dude I'm not doing this
again I want that friend in my life I
will never F this one up that girl I'm
not going to F this one up I want that
guy in my life to give me counsel I'm
always going to protect this and I'm
going to fear the man upstairs if I Fear
God because all of this stuff can be
taken away from me because I lost it all
early and I want that Grace I feel that
level of wisdom wisdom kindness energy
uh with him I think he's a star but I
think he's about to be a superstar I
think he's going to be I think 2024 he's
going to have a good year but I think
2025 for for jenko's going to be
skyrocketing I think and I think by that
point you know and and I agree with you
I mean he he really cross that interview
and I'm I'm excited to see what he does
next um and he told me some of his plans
but I think um I think by that point
we're all we're all talking like dude I
don't do I don't do grudges it's one
thing that I do not do and by the way I
never had a grudge there was there was
never a single because I'll be honest
like watching from the outside the
internet is ripe with assumptions it is
it is it is one of the most infuriating
things that you deal with having a
platform you guys all know this you're
you're well aware of this is this this
insane assumption engine and
misinformation engine that just churns
and I've preferred you know at times to
just say say what you want I don't I
don't give a I'm not going to sit
out here trying to correct y'all because
guess what I can't there's nothing I can
say that's G to make you think otherwise
it's just not right and so I think there
was a lot of assumptions and and listen
like things could have been handled very
very differently from all perspectives
no one was specifically at fall there
was things set out of anger
by I would say at some point or other by
every single one of the people involved
you know I like I said I was more in the
in the background of it just trying to
help facilitate a happy ending but from
the from the from the from the camera
side behind closed doors I have no let
me give you an idea like today uh a a
former competitor I used to be a part of
company I used to be part of 15 years
got a great experience there their main
guy who makes 10 15 million a year just
left last week yeah and it's a Well you
don't you and I haven't even talked
about this you know everyone what do you
think about this what do you think about
that I heard this story I heard Rico I
heard that I'm like listen don't believe
any of it just believe what's public and
what you see everything else is a show
there's a guy that makes up so many
stories about everybody and five years
later everybody realizes he was full of
he's so good at convincing
everybody some's going I'm not going to
mention who he is he knows who he is uh
but but but the point but the hang on a
second the point of the matter is this
here's the point I'm making the point
I'm making is the following I know
nothing about behind closed doors and
it's none of my business that's between
the three of you guys but the moment you
know when you turn on the camera like
for example who's the
guy who's the guy that paid this other
guy to have sex with his wife and what
is the whatever that guy's name so who's
this guy right the moment you choose to
do that to get subscribers and eyeballs
you can never get upset about somebody
asking you about that because you put it
out there for sure you know what I'm
saying who told you to do it don't do it
so if you don't want to be asked about
it you should have never done that clip
if you don't want to be trolled about it
you should have never done that why'd
you do that publicly You Want To Do
privately do your thing I don't care if
you want to do that privately but then
you're out there for for me if I start
talking politics and I'm talking
guess what who the hell am I to be upset
if I go on the bill Mar show and Bill
Mah wants to fight me and go back and
forth with me I have my opinion I risk
being out there but all I'm saying is
the behindth scenes stuff is between the
three of you but the one uh front-facing
the camera stuff look I mean he he was a
little bit bullied by his friend you
know Logan bullied him a little bit my
again front I'm not behind closed doors
I'm not off camera to see it when you
when you call somebody's Faith out and
and you hear some things like that uh uh
that's tough to do now again I don't
follow the whole thing closely to know
who said this maybe maybe Logan's
already apologized maybe they've had the
I have no idea all the follow-ups but
all I know is when when you when you're
in the space whatever the space is and
you see like those three guys running
together it's kind of cool man those
guys are doing a very good thing you
guys are doing your thing those guys
doing their thing you know you seen like
Andrew Schultz does his own show with
the oh I love it I love those guys that
it's the Cru right it works and that's
all it is I don't want to go any more
into the story I much rather fast
forward and go into other stor but I'll
give you the final thoughts if you want
to say anything about it and we'll
transition out I'm ready anything else
on this or no good all cool I just want
to Quick followup for you this has
nothing to do with this you're in a
precarious situation a lot of the times
because there's a similar theme we just
talked about the George thing talked
about the KSI I mean I've seen you on a
situation where you're literally in
between Jake and Logan like come on guys
you're like hey just sort of an innocent
bystander here even with Tate we know
that Jake's I'm sorry Logan's had beef
with with Tate but at the end of the day
you're on team Logan like you're not
gonna choose anybody over Logan right no
no that dude if you if if he
up and sorry for my my cursing If he if
he messes up um no of course you have
that kind of relationship 100% 100% if
you if you want to go back listen I've
always had the the um the like kind of
nickname of being this Yes Man okay if
you go back and you see who has said no
the most there have been some
opportunities that I've had that I
didn't take because of legal
ramifications because of ongoing you
know things that were going on that were
happening behind the scenes where I
couldn't do it whatever but but when off
on a on a on a topic me and him have had
falling outs where we didn't talk for a
month at a time because of things that I
said about him on other people's podcast
that I didn't agree with stances that he
had no I have no that that's that's the
thing that people make the mistake of I
owe a large chunk of my career to Logan
I owe a large chunk of My Success to him
he's he's a a good friend of mine um but
but but we are not I don't eat off his
plate you know what I'm saying I guess
in as it pertains to the podcast we
started the show together we've we've
done it all together it was his star
power that created the podcast but I'm
I'm a separate person you know what I'm
saying like he makes he makes mistakes
and does things that that's that do not
involve me whatsoever there's no
decision making anymore these days that
he makes that has my blessing my
discouragement so on and so forth you
know so when all the stuff when when
does hit the fan which it
inevitably will when you are when you
have the biggest Target on your back out
of any one on the planet besides maybe
Tate but there's a couple other people
right there's going to be a lot of as I
said misinformation assumption so on and
so forth all I can do is is is is just
continue you know being myself being
authentic to who I am and then yeah no
I've there's plenty of instances of me
calling him out plenty of instances if
you if people really wanted to research
they can go back to those episodes where
that Christianity conversation happened
the episode with Bobby Lee which was
very controversial with George and
you'll see me either stand up for
someone or stand against someone's
opinion I I by no means will ever fold
to someone else based on anything you
know if it's if it's fake drama or
wrestling stuff or or fighting then yeah
I'm gonna take his side 100% And even on
the the Jake and Logan when they had the
beef one like Lo U I think Jake wanted
to bring uh or the whole drink situation
with Prime and the fight everything with
that you're kind of stuck in the middle
here well whose side did I kind lean
towards
yeah I think you were on Jake's side a
little bit right correct correct so it's
like and I'm not I'm I'm on the side of
right that's that's what I prefer to be
on in life that is that is what I want
to do I wasn't always like that talk
about a segue that was not always my
life I was not always on the side of
right the side of empathy the side of
caring about other people and how they
feel and how their day is going to go
after you leave an imprint on them that
was not always me I was a piece of
and now a lot and now a big chunk of my
life is devoted to you yo how can I how
can I continue to to treat people well
and stand up for injustices when I see
them happening it doesn't matter who the
who's sitting next me I don't care who
it is Mike what's what's the biggest
difference between Logan and Jake
because the what a what a I mean Mom and
Dad should be sitting there saying like
did like is it is it the spirit of
competition that they're so flipping
competitive that they drive each other
like because it's it's a difference
between Tates uh Dynamic when you see
the two versus very different compliment
each other yeah these guys look like
absolute crazy crazy cycle competitive
is that a myre on how competitive they
are no they are they they both are and I
think and I think and I
think the difference between them and
the Tates is is Tristan I think is is
you know like his brother a very
powerful driven you know you know uh
opinionated person but I think he he he
is comfortable playing a complimentary
role to the big bad Andrew Tate you know
character and he's he's cool playing
he's cool being Pippen I at least it
seems like from the outside I don't know
if that's necessarily the case when you
get close to them and have those behind
the scenes conversation these two were
never going to be Jordan and Pippen it's
Jordan and Jordan or Jordan LeBron
they're not they're they're they don't
want it's not a it's not a I don't like
you they love each other but but damn it
seems like sometimes watching it that
competition can almost like start to
Haze over what what they really have
which is a Brotherhood I mean they're
freaking Brothers but they are so the
two guys are just so freaking driven you
know to to succeed but that's on the
younger brother cuz most younger
brothers are going to sit there and be
like all right that's my big bro and
you're by the way you're spot on with
trist I think I mean even you see old
fight footage of of Andrew and and
Tristan Tristan was the corner man he
was the cutman hyping him up like that's
has been his role and by the way Tristan
absolute stud gentleman we spent time
with him they're amazing but I think
there was something in Jake that he's
like nah I'm not I'm not going to be the
robin to your Batman I'm I'm gonna be
freaking Superman myself yeah and like
there's something happened and they I
know they grow up humble wrestling Ohio
so there must be some major competitive
fires going on comes from the it comes
from from Greg from the dad you know as
their their father is intensely compe
and and talk about conservative you know
like real deal like Backwoods Ohio like
you know and he's super competitive the
father yeah and his does he poke does he
drive or not really oh yeah okay I mean
there you go then that's pushes I think
it's worked for them meaning whatever
Tristan and Andrew Tate are doing has
worked for them espe especially now
they're in jail it's like teamwork
Brotherhood are they in jail right
now when they were
with what they're going through now when
they were just
in but these guys what made them great
in my opinion is they were both not
settling for number two but I tell you
but I tell you but but that's exactly
what it is because you
know the person that controls the two
boys being united or competitive is the
father yeah both things what you have in
common is a very strong father
personality right based on what you're
talking about and Emer and Greg right
now guess the best podcast would have
been the two fathers right but I think
his father passed away October 16 2015
can you can you check to see Emory Tate
when did he die are you big with stats
like that do you like big with days what
day did he die let's see what day
October 15 2017 october7 I'm sorry
October 17 2015 I was one day off so so
when you when you when you think about
fathers here's what you'll notice Adam
okay father on one side says if you guys
even fight each each other I'm the one
that's going to come and do this the
other one is poking against right
they're both effective but you know one
is going to lead to this and the other
one's going to lead to boom boom boom
boom boom regardless you're going to
know both of them you know but even deep
down inside that only works if the boys
have the psycho competitive DNA wiring
in them yeah and I think all four of
them got it you know Tristan if you're
around Tristan it's a very very
Tristan's a very interesting guy he
floats he doesn't even touch though he
just he just oh does he is he actually
able to levate such a bro he so
chill and a big Testament to we're
talking about brothers and the Loyalty
bro when they came to get Andrew Tristan
wasn't arrested he just was like
wherever my brother's going I'm going
with him like literally was just like
I'm they're like no you're not the rest
they're like no no I'm going wherever my
brother goes and that's like the
Testament of so what are you saying that
that Jake would just let Logan get
arrested and he'd stay home I don't I
don't know about I don't think feel like
most no I don't think would Jak's not
going to jail that's what I'm saying
he's not going what do you mean no let
me you guys got siblings yeah I have a
brother you guys going to jail with him
I would my brother h no dude you're
going up jail with the answer is no in
that situation if we're in a different
country and me and my brother about to
go into a freaking goog I'm going with
my brother my brother knows that yeah if
you're going into a Spartan fight you
one of you has to come out one of you
needs to stay out and get bail money bro
no no if me and my brother were in in
Tristan and Andrew's situation and
they're about to take me to some f that
it isn't America we're in a different
country I'm 100% Going my brother hands
down yes see so that's that's yeah I
guess if you're in a place where like
they're in Romania bro no the judge
doesn't speak English and the the guards
no I'm if you get arrested God forbid
Miami just call me I'm not going to jail
with you I'll bail you out bro I think I
I'm going to call IM and we'll go with
you he's coming go by the way let me I
don't think I don't think Jake would let
anything happen to Logan I agree 100% I
don't think Jake would let anything
happen to Logan and I think Logan uh uh
as an older brother sometimes you'll
test to see how much your brother can
take and I think he would jump in as
well but Andrew and and Tristan they're
gangsters I love it's a very different
mindset okay the mindset of a gangster
is no one is going to come in between us
any body that's again like I remember we
had a in the and this is why we get
along very easily like it was a natural
connection we had we're in the Army it's
me and my friend Jeff white guy from
Victorville California and we had a
couple other guys we had Mary and it was
mainly the three of us right we had a
couple other guys but it was mainly the
three of us if you even said one thing
listen me and Jeff are at lunch chow
hall we have a fight going on him and I
we're full on fighting we go afterwards
to the gym where racket ball is being
played two black girls are playing
racket ball we said do you mind if we
come in here real quick unless you guys
want to play with us we said absolutely
no I'm not even if he's listening to
this he will remind the
story I swear to God he will tell you
this you went into the ret ball we went
into the racket ball we asked the girls
to get out for 20 minutes I swear to
God what are you saying so Bradford's
been Bradford was so we get years
oldford Bradford yeah whiskey Bradford
yes so we get into a full-on fight right
guess what happens we're both bleeding
we went to the gym we worked out our
friends came and they're making fun of
us and then we fought them because we
can do this to each other you can't talk
to us like this who do you think you are
you're not in the circle don't even
think about like but that's the mindset
of a gangster gangsters are wired in a
different way the the gangster model is
it happens in business like Trump is a
gang gster it is certain basketball like
Michael Jordan was a gangster right Pat
Riley is a gangster it is a different
mindset you don't have to be politically
on the same side it's simply a way of
thinking that if you got forbid or no
longer loyal to me if somebody screws
you over dude we're rolling together
that's how we're rolling it's not that's
not you don't you don't see that very
often in in nowadays it's that's that's
a don't dise traditional thought like I
think back to my old lifestyle that is
in the fifth vital which you know you
read and and I think back to a time
where dude one cross word about you you
defended yourself half as hard as you
defended your friends if somebody you
people can come up to you and say a
bunch of and you're just n no I'm
not I don't want to catch another felony
tonight but one wrong word about your
your boy who might be a little bit
smaller bro you're you're it's it's
we're We'll All Die Here we could all
die here I don't care you know
what I'm saying like that that that
mentality exists I always think of the
movie The Town which is one of my movies
I know exactly what he goes in like I I
can't I can't tell you I can't tell you
what what we're doing I can't tell
where're going but we're going to hurt
some you can never bring you can never
ask me about again and he he doesn't
hesitate he goes whose car we taking
just instantaneous such a great scene
you've seen it on Instagram a million
because when you think about it a lot of
times it comes down to what are the
circumstances that you're up against as
a as a team of of course Logan and Jake
from their respective 20 and 25 million
Mansions behind the Gates of a you know
a gated community in Puerto Rico might
look at the the the circumstances that
they're up against differently than the
taper others who are who are facing a
you know other jailmates in a Romanian
prison right or or you know or or what
you were up against when you're in the
Army I think I think conditions in a lot
of ways dictate how you act as a human
in this world don't I don't disagree so
so now uh um you're living in California
right I want to read this you just
tweeted this okay California and you
said this about California now Vinnie
and I we've both lived in I lived in
California 20 some years almost 17 years
okay so here's years here's how he
paints California to be you ready
California is the girl you love so much
but she's going to ruin your life if you
don't get away oh D really sad because
it really is the most beautiful state
okay now Mike I've seen you also tweet
and you'll jump into chats and and
defend all sides right yeah you you'll
defend the the left liberal and what
about this and what about that and
you'll jump in in yon stuff you'll jump
in a bunch of people's stuff right but
how do you say the California is like
the the the left the Liberals heaven on
Earth where there's unicorns and there's
like you know that song remember that
one dog unicorn Neverending
Story That's California me ask you say
something like this ask question why do
you think I made that tweet that tweet
is exactly evidence of the of the
California that you're describing I fell
in love with California I fell in love
with that state I mean Dana White one of
the most you know right-leaning
conservative Free Speech free think
anti-establishment
people will say that California is the
most beautiful state in the country the
most hands down the most beautiful state
in the country um I I remember when I
went there he also said that Miami is
the new LA on let me get go ahead go
ahead but but but but but they got to
update that picture Dan I don't
appreciate that a lie no he's way better
looking we're getting on I'm going to
call Wikipedia 50 lb ago I I had dinner
with Dana two nights ago in Vegas he
does not look like that look years does
Wikipedia lean left
yet they're the founder but the current
Wikipedia yeah go ahead finish your
story you're say your Wikipedia was
great by the way I learned a lot from it
5'8 though yeah
58 um but but I I went out there for the
first time I think in 2016 and was
greeted by uh by a coastline by palm
trees by Hills by a a environment that
was alien to my to my eyes that had been
locked in into a hell of of an existence
for a decade and I I saw um this place
that was creative that was warm that was
um just just all encompassing of of of
the dream that that we have as creatives
in this country um and I I fell in love
and I said I will at the very least live
here but I probably will die in the
state and I and I cuz I so much fell in
love with it and where where
specifically with with Los Angeles with
California in general Mark Twain called
uh uh big sir you know he has this
beautiful love story about Big Sir and
there's a lot of beautiful places in
California but but I but La in specific
I just really had this had found a home
for myself there and and kind of you
know infamously bought this you know
four plus million dollar house there you
know a couple years ago and just have
been gung-ho had been you showed your
mom to the the H she was in tears
emotional yeah I remember that my mom's
been through a lot yeah been through a
lot and um
I'll be honest with you I haven't talked
about this uh but I have been I'm not I
can't get into too much detail but I've
been the victim of some crime in Los
Angeles uh a number of times I it's this
is completely not public no one knows
about it I don't talk about it at all uh
but but crime that is perpetrated by
some of the most ass backwards policies
that could ever be imagined I
mean just just disgusting Catch and
Release policy
that that almost reward criminal
behavior in a way that does not even
begin to make sense like like
who I we'll get into this now that we're
on to the series topics in a second
hopefully similar to the situation at
the border who the thinks that
these are these policies make any sense
disgusting it used to be I I committed
crimes I was I had to do I had to go to
court I had to
I was on you know a very short lease so
that if I did anything wrong again I was
going to do a 5-year prison sentence I
was given a little bit of of leniency by
by by people who believed in me and put
me into substance abuse programs and
helped me along the way but the I but my
crimes were not violent in nature they
were they were uh possession of of drugs
that I was using to harm myself these
people in in Los Angeles and and New
York City and some of these other places
and well yes let's all agree a lot of
blue States I I'm happy to talk about
policies in in a in a solitary nature
and discuss each Poli for people to hear
the fact that you probably identify
yourself as a blue yourself no not I I
I've I've always been policy based the
the this is something I was so excited
to talk to you
about the world is not black and white
if you
subscribe 100% wholly to the right or
the left in every single one of their
policies you're lying you're lying to
yourself you're not being truthful to
yourself because there are policies that
exist there are thousands of policies
and you're telling me that someone on
one side of the aisle has gotten all of
them right with the exception of none
like would you would you say that that's
the case I'm fully there okay okay gray
area there's a lot of factors involved
with a lot of policies how they exist
how they put into action how they're
executed in states that are semi blue
kind of blue kind of red there's so much
meat there that to be able to say I am
this side or that side which people do
which too many people are doing nowadays
is disgusting I consider myself nowadays
to be moderate right that's just where I
am but this has got to be very recent
though it's not it's really not it's a
it's a perception it's a perception a a
a perception that exists because of my
alignment with someone else it is it is
and by the way maybe even that's maybe
even that is a a miscalculation to to
assume that that Logan is a liberal
maybe in certain ways but but that's one
of the issues that I've been up against
on the internet has been me being in a
way defined by a relationship with
someone else we just spent one hour of
this show talking about that person
that's that's no no disrespect it's a
huge part of the story line but but
think about how much his actions have
trickled off to make people believe they
know me by way of who I'm friends and
who I work with yes who your circle says
something about you but it certainly
doesn't Define you to a tea it it just
doesn't right you're people say you're
you're a uh a result of The Five People
You spend the most of your time around
well you got one of them are you going
to take into consideration the other
four yeah so who influences you who
influences your
politics honestly I I like to believe
that a lot of it is is is driven through
life through personal experience which
which which is why I'm excited to be
sitting down with some people who have
that you know and have a conversation
with people who have probably been
through a lot of things in their own
lives I think that you gain a lot of
your own perspective in life through
experience the idea that you're going to
be 22 years old and you're just going to
have you're going to develop a a set of
bulletproof policy principles based on
someone else's speech is crazy to me
yeah M my asked you a question too bro
so what living in Cali I was there for
Pat moved you were you were in Dallas
and then you came here right Pat so I
was there I was there during the Trump
thing and as a standup mic you know they
locked everything down if I even
mentioned Trump on stage and and I'm not
a political comedian but once in a while
I make something funny to try to PE
don't talk about that comedy club Owners
like yo you can't you can't be talking
about this guy what what do you think
your what cuz for me it was dude Trump
that was it like everybody just split
right down the middle and I didn't even
know what left or right or anything was
till this cat came in I swear to God
even as a military talking about Trump
Trum Trump came in and then I I swear to
God I didn't know what left or right was
and then I came I go oh okay now I see
the split what was what do you think was
your the sh for you where you were like
oh my God like Call's just going down
because why would they incentivize they
they defund the police they tell uh
people you could steal under a thousand
bucks they're making these criminals you
you're yourself you're basically saying
that you're a victim what was that shift
and why are they giving these criminals
such a leeway to get out and keep doing
this there has to be a plan what are
they doing I don't I don't know that's
my that's my question I don't I just
don't understand it I don't understand
you know I've heard obviously all the
different you know uh IDE ideas around
Soros and funding and and and blue
States and what it does for for you know
for the for the
greater establishment if you want to say
that but I don't I some of these
policies seem so common sense okay we
had a we had a a m race in in Los
Angeles I'm sure you are familiar with
with Caruso
versus a lot of people wanted Caruso I'm
going to his house I'm going to sorry
the founder of Netflix was it the the SE
or
yeah in in Beverly Hills hosting these
things I'm looking around me all of
these people who seem to represent every
working class celebrity class money
class I'm saying to myself every single
person is behind this guy because of how
bad the city is right now the
homelessness the crime behind Caruso
everybody we were all there I'm looking
around me and I'm looking at the I'm
looking at the numbers start to creep up
and by the way Left Right Center they
were behind Caruso Caruso was one of
those mayors that actually people from
the left even Hollywood we're kind of
sick of it we kind of like this guy yeah
because because he was I like to say
that he was Trump without the theatrics
because you got to understand uh you you
did a you did a Twitter live the other
day um and and someone by the name of
good logic jumped in he was a speaker
and he said that he he's hoping that
Trump takes a more positive approach in
his campaign this year more positive a
little bit more relaxed in in in his
visceral towards uh the media
ferociousness towards everyone right and
I agree wholeheartedly I think very
similar to what I call Tate 2.0 he he he
he he was so boisterous to a point with
certain beliefs with certain uh uh
things that were meant to fire up a a
crowd to get them to kind of join and
and and and and and believe in him that
it got him in trouble to an extent that
it it shadowed all the really positive
stuff that he had to say to the young
man of this world about working out
eating the right things focusing on on
you know religion or or or whatever it
was at the time and I think you know in
a lot of ways Trump really needs to look
at the fact that he has a base that is
locked in he doesn't have to do the
reporter thing more he doesn't have to
call people fat he doesn't have to he
doesn't have to do that in fact I
believe that's some of the stuff that
works against him as he as he continues
to try to Garner the the moderate right
because listen like he's got his side
locked in m magga is ready to rock
they're they're ready to go you know
what I'm saying but but he doesn't need
just the anti-establishment he needs a
good chunk of the
establishment establishment as well and
I think that the rhetoric calm down that
Tate fact fashioned is important for
Trump in this election as well or at
least will will behoove and benefit him
and so what I say that is because
Caruso business owner billionaire owns
The Grove owns a bunch of commercial
real estate but was softspoken I want to
do this I want to help these people I
have a plan this is my plan none of the
none of the you're fat you're a
any of that type of I that's
paraphrasing right but that type of
visceral didn't do it didn't do it
because I think he knew
that but now you look at the results and
he lost so I don't know yeah I don't
know I don't know what what the right
thing was and and I hear you saying this
and it's going to I mean easier said
than done with all the stuff that
they're doing to Trump since then to now
Mike I I see the reservation right now
from him he's kind of being cool but
dude it's going to be hard because you
know the cheating the all the media
stuff all the what they're indicting him
and everything and he's still kicking
ass I I'm I'm hoping that what you're
saying is that he just plays it cool cuz
everybody's you know why they're all
scared he's going to come in and on
everybody which in all fairness he he
has to me the green light to do whatever
the hell he wants to do in the sense
that they've been doing nothing but
trying to cheat and keep him out of
office a fair duly elected dude they
started from 2016 it hasn't stopped if
you think about it from Hillary Clinton
till right now today in court to this
very day it's anti-trump he's the evil
racist this and then and now we're
hearing stories where what even Snoop
Dog now is you know you know what he's
actually a g I just think there's I just
think there's like similarly to what we
talked about with the situation with the
show and how it played out like looking
back there's just so many things that
could have gone differently like like I
watched the um Shapiro Destiny debate on
Lex fredman which I think did you see
that I haven't seen he told me about it
I haven't seen Le Lex fredman obviously
incredible just just inquisitive you
know investigator and and and
interviewer put these two guys down
together for what I would consider be
one of the more just relaxed and
respectful interviews that exist in the
in the political space like like just a
really you know um very respectful you
know argument and they had a full
breakdown of of j6 and the way that they
they both kind of agreed
that that that just W like like the the
that just wasn't a win a a game plan win
for Trump and how that and how that
worked out there were mistakes made the
the the the courts that that
investigated it all the investigations
have led to absolutely no evidence that
there was any kind of interference with
that with the election or enough
interference as
claimed by by the Trump Camp to
influence the outcome of the election
but but then to say that there was an
Insurrection incitement on Trump was was
reaching too far but but I think
everyone was in agreeance there that
that it was it was not the best idea for
him to claim that he had won that
election what what are your thoughts on
that do you think that that there was
election interference absolutely but
what does that mean though so you got to
unpack what election interference means
yeah what do what do you mean by
absolutely yeah I mean what did what did
the judge say the other day on what
happened in Arizona you know this many
uh uh that people counted for that many
uh uh in court and they're just kind of
talking about in Congress yeah but okay
let's go through levels of it right from
the lowest to the highest lowest level
uh every single person in Main stream
media called him to be a Russian spy or
Russian connected this you know
sponsored by Russia everything Hillary
Clinton said that he was doing she was
doing I mean that's that's the gamesman
of Hillary Clinton you got to
respect what she does right so the
mainstream media played the role of
selling him as the monster that he is
number two if you want to talk about
election fraud when the New York Post
story came out with a hunter Biden
laptop
50 of the highest ranking
officials in CIA came out saying that
this laptop story is fake 50 they said
this is fake and but let me ask you let
me ask you a quick question just to hop
in for a sec th this is the this is the
uh part of the dialogue that and also I
don't I don't know how deep I want to
get into this stuff because you made a
You made a point earlier you didn't know
understand left vers right politics
until Trump came on right do you ever
wish we could go back do any of you guys
ever wish we could go back do you ever
wish we could go back to a time
where the we talked about the president
of the United States on one day out of
the Year who'd you vote for today oh
dope cool did you see the Lakers
Golden State game last night that is one
of the alltime classics LeBron vers
Steph Curry to the death free throws
three-pointers I'm your friend you're my
friend I'm not saying policies issues
the things that are affecting us are not
most average person would agree with you
but I'm going to tell you story and I'm
going to finish the thought as well when
you ask a question about so for me the
whole New York Post thing is you keep
that story away from the people let me
just write this on so I can tell you the
story so uh you keep that story from the
people and you New York Post calls
Twitter Twitter doesn't put up oh
yeah we're not going to put it up
because of this and it was going viral
and that could have been the difference
on who you going to vote and then you
bring these 50 CIA agents who are
professional Liars to say the fact that
yeah you know this was it's just a con
job it's not a real story then Camala
Harris First turns around and says I
would never do the vaccine with this
much of research that took place
especially under a trump Administration
and when does the fiser vaccine come out
that's ready or the Johnson and Johnson
and Mna you know when 2 days after
election is over with the number of
timings that happened on when they
launched the vaccine that was done by
trun 2 days later on Thursday they say
the vaccine is ready but let me go back
to the question about do you wish we
could go back to
XYZ okay um it's a very tricky question
the answer will be what am I solving for
if I'm solving for Pure oblivious
happiness yes 100% I want to go back to
it but if I'm solving for life to be a
man that
defends and and and is able to fight for
some people that maybe they can't and
God put certain things in my heart that
I can't stop thinking about and he he he
allows you to use certain weapons and
gifts to fight off the bullies and you
see that as a responsibility no I'm kind
of glad I know about it because for me
I'm not solving for the oblivious
happiness when I was a kid when I say
kid I'm 22 years old I had an uncle of
mine I've told the story to you before
had an uncle of mine his name Albert
love this man till today
I've never met a human being happier
than Albert never when I tell you I've
never Sur I've never met a human being
happier than Albert I miss him so much I
love him so much he's not doing well
health by I ask my dad every time if
anybody from Albert's family's seen this
please share this with him Al I love
you oh this guy would give me $100 when
our family did have a nickel to our name
his gift and he was always so nice to me
always talked me like I'm a grown man he
would build me up and he's such a gentle
guy right my dad told me this one day
Albert would come to house on Sundays if
we were lucky every other Sunday he'd
come to the house well my dad and I
would roommates at 21 years old when I'm
21 this is after the Army I'm just like
a whole different life at this point and
he would come he says put in Kings of
Comedy and I would put Kings of Comedy
and he says go to Bernie
Mack two 4 6 Lord come help me baby this
mother you know that whole scene right
course I've seen that a few hundred
times because of Albert and he would sit
there and I would
say do you understand what they're
saying not at all not one thing zero but
I love this black man oh my
God my uncle loved Bernie and then one
scene this is this is a very important
scene he's over there sitting on the
couch the TV is there our living room
small 4 500t apartment right this is the
kitchen there's a all between the
kitchen and there and that's the fridge
in the corner right and my dad comes he
says TI come here Patrick he
says look at him look how he's laughing
you will never meet a happier man than
this he said be careful reading all the
books that you're reading because you
will never have this wow what a freaking
thing to say he said be careful reading
the books you read because you will
never have this innocent happiness ever
again because when you become become too
smart and you're reading constantly
wanting to find out the different
purpose of it's a curse absolutely a
double-edged look at Lenny from Mice and
Men exactly that's right those poor
puppies remember never forgive him for
what he did to that dog I had to read
that in high school what's the moral of
the story the moral to answer your
question for you if I'm s if I'm solving
for what I'm solving for all day long
I'm glad we're learning about it because
they're use they're showing they're
showing their cards on how they want a a
to control you and why they want to
control you and why they want that kind
of power over you and I and it's
actually very interesting case study to
look at the way they're doing it and to
me I sit there and I say okay I actually
think the last four years were terrible
for establishment people because you
know why because they thought they had
it it's done this is their chance don't
worry even if we're public about it
right now go go go hurry up go go
broke this broke oh don't worry go go
everything's breaking go go go go
oh we didn't make it now they know
yep what the hell do we doing I think
that's what happened Oh you mean that's
where we are right now yeah yeah for
sure no for sure dude no no one yeah
sorry and but M and here's the thing
though bro they had a chance they had a
chance this three years we're going to
go on for they had a chance to go hey
guys this Trump racist the everything
economy blah we're going to show you
they had all this time and just like you
just nailed
everything is broken there's leaks and
everywhere this the ship is sinking
but they're like no no come on open Bard
everybody come here and this is the
thing Mike just just to really fast to
interject I I I not saying ignorance is
bliss but to go back then I think now
that Trump and dude again God chose this
spray taned whatever guy you're fired he
pulled open a curtain and he went hey
everybody look and now there's no going
back the fake news yes he said it crazy
cuz he's not a public speaker he pulled
open the curtain showed everybody hey
guys I'm sacrificing this all cuz his
name is screwed he's about to go to jail
he said look at them this is the people
that I was cool with the swamp that he
was talking about I turned on them and
now look at them showing their faces and
he did it and I I think he did it he got
in way too deep way too fast but now
there's no turning back that's it I just
I just don't I don't know I just don't
have that level of trust in in like in
any like even like like you talk about
like anti-establishment right like he's
got he's got Nicks in his armor on on
anti-establishment as well you know what
I'm saying I mean you know the the VAC
Trump the vaccine case for him was was
yeah well do you know how I do
anti-establishment establishment how
very simple give everybody a score right
for example you know how Andrew Cuomo
right I said this four years ago the the
santis people keep putting you back up
because they're like I can't believe
you're support you said this about
Andrew let me say it to you again to the
Dan santis Community whom I love dearly
ready I said it four years ago I said
Andrew Kom may be the best candidate for
president Democrats have I still stand
by that because to me Andrew KO is an
anti-establishment
Democrat that's why the establishment
Democrat hates Andrew Kumo they can't
stand them because they can't use them
see see the the the establishment to me
with Trump you're going to Trump okay
score Trump as establishment
anti-establishment because we can score
everybody like if we score Biden he's
100% establish 100% okay you go to new
Newsome is establishment right Mitch
McConnell establishment right you go to
all of these guys you can score them you
can go to Andrew Kom maybe different
kind of establishment right you put him
at a 50-50 or 6040 or 7030 Trump of
course there's 10 20% establishment but
it's 80% anti-establishment can I can I
ask you one question about that when you
when you say anti-establishment it's
almost weird because to be to be
on okay like the right side is obviously
is obviously Pro small government right
to to be on the right you you you don't
want the government in your business
right but to be to be on the right you
also have to be a believer in the
original form of establishment which is
the Constitution of the United States of
America do not do not feel like the
constitution in some way contributes to
what at least be ended up becoming
The Establishment yeah but the
Constitution was to protect you and I
like what was the purpose of you having
freedom of speech so you can say
whatever you want to do to protect We
the People second amendment was to
protect We the People freedom of press
was to protect who we the everything is
to protect you and I so so the concept
is the the collective and the individual
right is Pump Up the collective we but
at the same time you better make sure
you recognize the individual we we've
gone all here we don't recognize the
individual anymore we demonize the
individual Trump's a bad man Elon Musk
bad man these people are bad people
these billionaires are bad people right
The Establishment has got a very
different uh uh uh thought pattern than
you and I do the establishment doesn't
want you and I to think for ourselves
The Establishment doesn't want ideas
being challenged The Establishment wants
to make you and I look here and get
distracted from what's really going on
here on the most unique days they'll
pass a bill or a law that nobody's
paying attention to it this isn't this
isn't the Constitution isn't the
establishment the Constitution was
actually built to fight against the
establishment that they were
experiencing in to protect from of
course what we had before that's the
whole concept of what was I think the
Perfect Analogy is what you talk about
in the book The Barbarians the
bureaucrats The Establishment is the
bureaucracy it's the red tape basically
it's it's the it's the institutional not
the institution it the what's How does
it go in the bar The Visionaries the
George Washingtons of the world the
prophet okay The Barbarians the Builder
Explorer the administrator the Barbarian
the bureaucrats and a sinner just brings
it all together and you bring up a good
point with the Declaration of
Independence in the US Constitution
that's great that's the framework for
what we're talking about today but then
they add the the the pork and the
bellies and the and the
bureaucracy and everything on that you
see what's going on in California how
much R I'm glad you went there so are
you at a point where you're willing to
leave her California uh
um yeah I mean I got to get out from
under a $4 and half million dollar house
in in a in a soft Market because of
rates sense you know what I'm saying and
so that's going to take a minute but
yeah I'll come to Florida okay my
girlfriend's here I mean I'll come to
I'll go to Texas I I love a lot of
people in Texas I'll go to I'll go to a
state you know what honestly I think as
you as you whether you make money or
don't make money as you age you start to
put a a price on feeling safe I like I
say that like it's a novel idea
dude Los Angeles is horrible it
is insane bro I would
not like my mom's coming there I have
LAPD at the house you know what I'm
saying like she they'll be there the
whole time she's there is that crazy
that you have to do that the whole time
she's there I'm the only one who has
never lived in La I mean I've been out
there sort of a little vacations a
little bit I'm a Miami guy rank in order
especially since you've made money you
came from Connecticut you was broke you
didn't have any money you came to La
rank the order in which why you're
leaving taxes homelessness crime
regulation but what is it cuz I hear
everything and everything aboute you
want to know you know you want to know
what's weird about it because of where I
the things that I come from and the
things that I went through in my life I
have I have empathy for situations and
policies in different in different
perspectives than other people might
when it comes to something like
homelessness i i i i it's almost hard
for me to be angry about that because of
how I feel feel for these people many of
them Veterans of this country many of
them brothers sisters uh people have
fallen victim to to substance abuse
people have been have been screwed over
by the system because of lack of
resources in this country and so for me
to say oh that's such an eyesore oh such
an eyesore and they're so like that
couldn't be me because that was me that
was me that was you you know what I'm
saying to an extent right like so I that
one's always been tough for me because I
just so like for me it's it's softness
on crime is got to be number one what
are we do that softness on violent
crime what are we doing what is the
point of being soft on violent criminals
that that has to be the most spit in the
face to a to a positive uh culture and
environment that could ever exist what
are we doing what is the point of that
of of of saying okay this person just
went and violently assault Ed a woman or
or anyone and and he is going to come in
he's going to fill out a piece of
paperwork and leave the police station
insan with with no bail with no bond and
no promise to he's just gone right like
ridiculous that's insane number two
number two is got to be taxes because
let me tell you what's worse than paying
the country's highest tax rate which is
which I do cities by city I pay 40 uh I
pay 39% Federal I pay 133% state and I
pay 1%
uh Los Angeles city tax I am in the
highest tax bracket that exists in this
nation okay so 14 half the money is gone
gone let me tell you what sucks let me
tell you what sucks worse than paying
that tax percentage paying it and not
seeing anything happen as a
result of it you look around you
everything is broken all the stores are
boarded up all the people are now we get
into the homeless thing we're we're not
doing anything we're not we're not
making advances in in mental illness
assistance and substance coverage in in
in homing for these people so so number
two would be taxes and and number three
would just
be I think one and two covers it I mean
I mean it's like it's like it's like
what else do you need to say when you're
being when you're being betrayed by the
the the the People by you ask a great
question to to kind of make a a one
thing right on why you're leaving and
you you kind of having to sit there and
kind of go through the process but you
know I ordered a book one time we're
playing this game with our crew our guys
I want them to think about you know in
the insurance business you're building
your own office well I want you to read
this book book of the month how to build
your own country build your own country
yeah how you build your own country how
do you build it I never thought about
starting my own country okay well now do
go think about it what is the most
important thing that's the book by the
way right there it was a kids book
what's the most important thing
seriously that's the book it's a it's a
really good book that's the same book
Nome
read to design California please don't
come to my house leave me the alone
but now you can never leave California
after what you just said but but no no
but but so you read this and and you
think about who is the most important
person to decide what country the family
is going to move to by far and away it's
the kids it's the mother feeling one
Mother exactly which is what word it's a
one word it starts with the letter S
it's Safety Safety and Security safe and
by the way look what he's saying though
I know he he's saying mom's got to come
over she best feels safe I'm with my
girl I better feel safe Jen and I we
move into our first house after we get
married couple months after we get
married we went to this house off of
anino Boulevard whatever it was off of
Balo and Northridge down the street from
our office okay uh uh so
okay got a Range Rover I parked the car
outside we're having our first kid guy
breaks into my car takes my uh uh what
do you call it backpack everything that
I have system stereo everything Brandon
Ranger over takes it okay all right
let's go buy a bunch of guns I'm a
military guy so guess what I'm good
let's go buy a bunch of guns we go buy a
bunch of guns you got to wait a month no
problem all right cool come to the house
great then I'm sitting there saying so
let me get the straight a guy is this
close to the front door and there is no
guy at the gate yeah I'm not good with
this so we got to go to a different
place so then I go find a gated
community we move instantly because when
I'm on the road you can't come mess with
my family it's just uh you know the
natural DNA the wiring we have and when
do you have kids or I don't when you
have kids life changes in a very weird
way very weird way and and like right
now I'm texting my wife because two of
my kids are not feeling well so I'm like
here but I'm also checking to see how
they're doing yeah I stop by sent out
today to just go check on her before I
went to a meeting at the house just
checking on the family they're good but
you know father thinks that way we go
into the gator Community secure we come
here security everything like number one
just to simplify you can list 50
different things but it starts off with
security but but here's to go off where
you're at because I think you asked the
question because I think you have one
thing in your mind that you're not ready
for but you know that decision is coming
in about N9 and a half months let me
tell you what that decision is you ready
it's a beautiful decision there's this
month um in in um 2024 it's going to be
the first Tuesday of this month I think
it's November right I love that
month so this what is it going to what
is it going to do for the city what no
please answer this what is it going to
do for going to do for what is the vote
going to do a lot bro how how because
because listen this is not this is not
new this this is not this is not federal
policy this is not this didn't just
start four three years ago four years
ago this has been going on there's been
a robbery crew going on there's been a
murder crew going on so so that that
putting someone else that that's that's
the thing we we talk constantly
constantly and this isn't wrong and and
is it wrong this is what I asked you
earlier it's not wrong to have this
discussion but why are we not having
conversations about local policies why
are we not as a collective in this
country because it's because it's become
celebritie and people are not having
enough conversations around what is
happen in their Community we have become
hyperfocused on National and Global
geopolitics and everybody wants to be an
expert on what's going on in Gaza but
people aren't saying holy the
person I voted into office a
in my city but but by the way so
so one can do both right and for us like
the the the perspective I look at it is
one I I see myself that wherever I go I
want to improve it it doesn't matter
where I go I don't care where I'm in the
insurance industry I want to improve it
the insurance industry changed my life
so we have one meeting every year that
is my favorite meeting every year I
started this meeting in 2015 and every
year in December first week of December
I bring the CEOs and the top executives
are the biggest life insurance companies
they come and I call it the carrier
meeting typically they spoil us this is
my chance to spoil no one in the
marketpl does this but us and they all
say it they say Pat's the only person
that can bring all his girlfriends in
the same room and we all get along
because they're all competitors they
can't stand each other Market wise now
we're all friends and I say this this
industry changed my life I owe back to
the industry because it changed my life
okay uh uh whether it comes down to
State military country America it
doesn't matter what it is America
changed my life and your vote matters a
lot because people listen to you why do
they listen to you
so sometimes we think the people have
the most influence or the governors or
the Senators or that big famous guy that
went to Harvard now sometimes the people
that have the most influence are just
regular guys that are like dude what the
what is going on here right what is
going on here and to me a part of it is
right now specifically like you can
change the city you're living in right
but imagine if you
knew when did you move you said 2016
first time you went to California right
but when did you you bought the house in
2020 or 2022 2021 2021 okay when did you
live in California 2022 oh really you
lived in California 202 no no no I I
moved to California 2018 okay but then
you bought the house in 2022 okay so
2018 when you moved I I if in in the two
incidents you had that nobody knows
about you've never publicly talked about
it right three incidents okay if
somebody told you that would have
happened would you have bought the house
in California would you have moved to
California I don't know if I would have
even believed it I to be complet I I
probably would have put I probably would
have waited to touch the burner I agree
with you by the way full and by the way
how many your answer how many people in
America do you think are in your in your
situation that's saying there's no way
in the world that's true I would assume
most most do you agree cuz I agree I
think most people are there so what
happens to a person like you is dude
trust me never in a million years did I
believe any of this stuff but I went
through it and here's what it was like
he's saying it what there's no way that
would have came from you so for you to
say what you said 2024 November the one
thing we can do every November is vote
you have options you have Trump on one
side Biden's on the other side what are
you doing I'm not even looking at people
I'm voting on policies okay at this
point I want I don't want to even see a
face and right now I don't like how a
lot of the the only thing I will say is
is maybe it's just all smoking mirrors
but the economy is is the the market at
least is is doing well the market all
let's let's be
honest High the Market's doing well I
believe joblessness is also down
unemployment is I think at three and a
half% people think inflation's still at
10% it's at 3 so it's like I there's a
difference between Main Street and Wall
Street though M and for sure like I said
smoking mirrors but I think I think um I
think we just we all just need to be a
little bit
more I just hate pigeon holes I just
hate I think we've all become not maybe
not everyone here but but like a good
majority of the country have become
pigeonholed into this belief that
there's a savior in the form of a
candidate and and everything's black and
white and there's no gray area or let's
take a little bit of this or I just want
what works the and and I'll tell you
what I'll tell you what this year is not
going to be the case I can already
tell when we look back 50 years from
now a hundred years from now and we and
we like like we do now we look back at
Lincoln or we look back at Washington or
we look back at you know
Eisenhower like any of these people that
were the the ones the ones bro the one
or an anti-establishment guy JFK
whatever right like as we look back and
we look at these heartbeats right these
drum beats of American exceptionalism as
it pertains to presidency right in my
eyes and it won't be in this election
the president from this realm in this
area will be the uniter will be the
uniter not the breaker because we're not
close it's not like it's an 8020 thing
we have two sides of this country we
have a we have a divisive 5050 4951 4852
split and guess what there ain't no hope
in sight there's no hope in sight Trump
is not going to come into office and
unite the aisles Biden sure as hell is
not going to even unite what he's eating
for lunch the next day he doesn't it's
not going to happen Okay in my
eyes I want a candidate who says I am so
sick of this divisiveness that I'm going
to put it to an end okay this country as
a political uh player has become a
basketball game where there are two
teams who are intent on blocking each
other's shots neither wants to score
neither want the only thing they want to
make sure is that the other team doesn't
score block the bill block the bill
block the bill block the bill we are a
in a handicapped disabled paralyzed
government that is one side versus the
other side and my eyes the person that
comes along that will be remembered
anytime soon will be the uniter not the
breaker who is going to is it going to
be pbd is it Go who is going to come up
and say yo you know what enough is
enough stop your little bicker and
I'm anti- this you're anti-
that screw you screw you learn how to
work together you want to be the head of
a business you've grown multiple
businesses to hundreds of millions of
dollars if you saw a disagreement
between your top players you're not
going to pick a side you're going to say
yo learn how to work together or you're
out that's it there's no more
learn to work together this is our team
we're on the same Mission and we're all
going the same place whether you like it
or not if you can't get with it to get
the out because because we we have
so much division in this country so many
people that just want to see the other
side lose and and it it has to stop
that's that's my belief by the way so uh
that's what Adam was talking about on
the the different stages we go through
and look at what Dana White does here's
the UFC say Hey you he about the uh uh
the the tonality with the racism that
just took place about what racism well
Israel said this and he used the nword
he's he's
black well he said this what are we
talking so let me get this straight are
people on the left complaining a
and yeah I bet they would they probably
would but you know and you're like oh
how do you dis like you know you
have a leash on these what leash what
are we talking so Dana does that with
the sport and that's why he does so well
and you got some sports that they're
caving but but the reality part of it is
the
following you know different times will
give birth to different types of leaders
you said something about a savior like
we're all waiting for a savior to come
right well I mean if you're if you're a
man of Faith your savior is not a yeah
you already have it and you're not
relying on other human being to do that
com back also you're sitting there
you're kind of like you know Faith
here's where I'm at this is this is
where I'm banking I'm banking on you
know where I'm at with my faith great
but let's talk about the leadership side
um you know I also think in
everything the temperature also
decreases When the Right leader shows up
and you no longer worry about certain
things I'm talking to Bill Maher and I
said Bill I've never been to your studio
before okay I've never been to what is
it called it's called uh uh uh uh Rob
what's it called the it's which one Club
random way been on a show I was on a
show last so I'm in club random and I'm
looking around I'm like dude a freaking
sick set first of all his house is
insane 5 acres and Hollywood Hills all
this stuff but I'm
like that couch to me is a colorful
couch I've never seen a colorful couch
like this this picture here the pizza
man thing the movie thing the bar over
there you go to the back with the
engineers he's got the Trump stuff there
he's got the Obama stuff he's got the
George Bush toilet paper he's got all
this weird stuff in there right but let
me tell you pool table in the middle
cool I said for me I came here
everything here is new for you
everything here you've already seen so
you don't look at it anymore it's called
a law of familiarity it's a law right
it's very normal this is why husband and
wife are married H it's my wife it's my
old girl
you right yeah oh it's just this it's
that and oh it's just my dad and then
your dad passes away oh yeah oh
it's just my mom and oh oh it's
just oh what the dude what a so for me
when you have a leader in
house that puts the fear into the enemy
where no war is started under him for
four years and he was supposed to start
World War III and then he's gone and the
first thing you think about is security
you're thinking about it from the state
standpoint but in your country you got
Afghanistan you got Ukraine you you got
Russia you got Israel you got Hamas
Syria you got Gaza now you got Iran now
you got all this stuff with houes now
three soldiers get killed by Iran all
this stuff is happening first thing you
say is dude the temperature what
happened to the other guy we kind of uh
uh didn't like at all where is that guy
twet where where where is that guy
where's that and by the way FYI this guy
this guy's he's not at all Trump just so
you know that right he's not so but when
you sit there and you kind of go through
this process then you're like okay so
maybe there's somebody that can come and
lower the temperature today is he going
to be the guy that's going to be the
biggest synergist and do that it's
probably not going to be in his profile
because anything you say to him he has
to respond back immediately just kind of
what of his DNA
is but maybe there's going to be
somebody else that comes next or far
where are where are they synergist yeah
yeah because because like even just in
the way that people communicate yeah
it's it's important to communicate like
like you you are once again back to you
as a business leader you would you make
sure that the way that you communicate
with people even if you even if you
dislike them at any certain time even if
you you know don't you know feel well
about them you're you're either going to
speak with them with respect or you're
going to get rid of them right but for
the most part you approach your
conversations with empathy and respect
right absolutely always and I feel like
that as a table stake has been lost on
both sides to be honest I feel like I
don't know it just it the way the
government looks right now to from my
side on both sides is kind of
embarrassing I I'm sorry I think it's I
think it's just embarrassing I think I
think people are behaving childishly I
don't think they're looking at the big
purpose when when we go to war you you
say you know the first thing I'm
probably thinking is uh you know where
where's the last guy that we had the
first thing I'm thinking was damn I wish
that the rest of the people in my
country were United that's what I'm
thinking I'm I'm saying to myself damn I
I wish my brother and and and the
neighbor next to him were saying I can't
wait to go to war with you I'll die for
this country cuz guess what they're not
saying that they're saying you I'm
not going to war with this guy I don't
want to be I don't like this guy who did
that though so who did that well listen
as he said earlier he never thought
about right vers left and I'm not saying
I'm not saying that I'm not saying
anyone's to blame but I will
tell you
this cuz I know what you're going to say
I know you well I don't know what you're
going to say but I'm assuming you're
going to say that divisiveness started
with Obama right I I don't know where do
you where do you where do you think
where do you think that that start let
me let me give my site although a lot of
people would say Obama but that's not
where I'm going to go here's where I'm
going to go so for me when you when you
think about that whole you know division
of people arguing from one side to the
other hey my brother with me we're going
to be together when 9/11 happened that's
exactly what happened it's exactly what
happened true true we we nobody gave a
like nobody even thought about
politics also wasn't but it also wasn't
we didn't have the political Arena that
we have right now but hear me at the
time you're right so what was the
difference between today and 2001 there
was no social Med Med there was no
immediate reaction there wasn't there
wasn't there wasn't freaking Tik Tok and
China indoctrinating our youth but also
think about it there wasn't 5,000 small
CNN on Fox you realize there is 5,000
CNN's and foxes today but you can't but
you can't say that that's not a good
thing because then that would be anti
Free Speech but that goes that goes back
to my point if I'm solving from being a
a oblivious happy person yes but I'm
glad I'm not because I'm not solving for
that what I will tell you kind of messed
the whole thing up this time when 911
happen when uh Co happened everything
was Trump's fault it was all here we we
couldn't all mainstream had to do
mainstream is not controlled by the
right zero it's all left all mainstream
media had to do was unite behind China
being the enemy they couldn't do it and
by the way you know what they all agree
on now left and or right China is the
enemy you still can't hold them they
couldn't do it four years ago but but do
we also agree do we also let me let me
pose this question when did we also get
kind of soft on Russia not being not
being what the enemy like like like for
example like my mom grew up hiding under
her desk in drills waiting for a Russian
attack on on us soil right how old how
old was your mom though that was in 19
that was in the50s and0 she did the
right yeah you know what I'm saying like
that's by the way all of our no no no no
I understand that but but like but like
do we look at Russia the same way that
we look at China or because that's
that's see that's so that's what I'm
saying like we had Russ Russ wait but
Russia didn't do anything for for four
years I mean obviously overall threat
but for those four years absolutely
nothing happened but then Biden comes in
and he literally looks at a camera and
says if Russia wants to do a minor
incursion in Ukraine I'm fine with it
that's inviting a war to happen
that's stupid I agree but I think Mike's
Point is Russia's not our Ally let's not
pretend I know how we got there seem
this admiration for
Putin I want say admiration but when you
have a when you have a leader that's
like listen why am I going to start
with somebody why can't I just be cool
with everybody cuz but let's not get
well that's not that's not
Putin I'm saying guys let's just be real
Putin's a he murders and he's a crazy
kill don't let's not forget that we had
a President Bush Jr that started an
illegal War weapons of mass
Destro and we killed Millions I don't
we're evil they're evil but they weren't
doing when Trump was in let's
answer that let's address that question
with Russia Mike look at it this way
okay look at it this way who
was um the chief's number one
enemy yesterday the ners or or I mean I
mean yesterday the Ravens the Ravens
who's their enemy today the ners okay
who was the Niners number one enemy
yesterday Detroit who's their enemy
today the Chiefs okay meaning when Co
happened your number one enemy is who
you're facing today which is China and
we couldn't do that that doesn't
discount the enemy we went up against
before of course that person's an enemy
no but I know but it seems like but it
seems like the the lens for
enemies has shifted on both sides like
it seems like yeah I agree with you I
think there's been some softness from
the left towards China I also think but
I also think that there's been softness
from the right towards Russia I this is
one of those this is one of those things
that once again first of all that I'm
definitely not qualified to speak about
but to me becomes something that is that
is gray area and invites the question
that I asked once again back to Lenny
from Mice and Men where we going with
all this I I love you asked me a
question where where's my vote going I I
have certainly lean started to lean more
towards the conservatives and I prefer
and I prefer to just take the faces and
the icons and the celebrities out of it
and be like dude what policies do we
need here to save the the the sport of
women racing to to be just women or or
or for or for you know like people who
beat the out of people to not just
get out of jail or for or you know what
I'm saying like some of these things or
for the Border to be protect you want
have kids yes I would like to wait till
you have kids wait till you have kid
slow down a I know it'll it'll be even
more no because when when you when you
okay when when you don't have kids
you're naturally not concerned about
everything like who gives a about
that yeah because you don't have any
kids right the moment you have kids dude
what what do you think what happened to
you in three years huh no no I've always
been like this no you haven't like I've
not always been like this things change
as life also changes for you no but but
for me what you're saying is this best
part is following best part is when you
start asking the right questions in life
that that's how it starts so you first
ask the right question and then the
other part is on you to be curious to go
find the answers to the question that's
how it starts you know why get married
why should I just stay single okay
that's good you're asking a question to
go to like I would ask the question why
I have kids and you're like oh dude why
would I want to do this when you're
going through the process of wanting to
do your due diligence but but you're
already there you know for me right now
with with where we're at you know with
with America when you're saying
Republicans are not defending Russia and
all this other stuff I
think in sales you go to a client's
house most people who have never been in
sales they think sales is about making
the most incredible
presentation it is a part of it but very
small very small part of the sale a
great salesperson asks the right
questions finds the whole to fill when
you ask the right question
you caus the client and individual to
think and then they already closed
themselves because you asked the right
question so for example you talked about
Russia Trump asked a question no one's
ever asked he said why is there still a
NATO us or
S well I thought it was well I thought
it was to create an allegiance between
like-minded countries to to to ban
together in the face of Imperial evil of
some of some if you go look up the
history of it's purely against yeah but
no but it was but it was originally a
postor War II not a cold war initiative
if if you go look up like what the
purpose of when was NATO when was NATO
founded
if 19 what is it 49 49 so that's pre I
guess technically anything post
ww yeah but but but it was it was a it
was a an alliance so that we could band
together with the same people we had
just fought alongside against the most
evil people in point world so
now those guys are no longer around
Germany doesn't have the military they
had they used to have a bunch of Tanks
now they're lucky if if they have a
couple tanks nobody in Europe except for
two or three countries invest in their
military nobody does why would they they
don't need to do it Nat is just piggy
off we are F so the moment when he asked
the question yeah you're like oh it
is a good we've not asked that question
right so then guess who has the whole
you know military industrial complex
guess who has it Russia has it of course
what what does Russia do with their
military you know what Ukraine is going
through right now they can't get their
weapons anymore they no longer can build
those missiles anymore Russia's used to
pump out 40 missiles now they're doing
100 because they can afford to do it so
what happens now now NATO is relying on
us like oh no one's going to touch us
because America's got our back we're
putting the most money why are we
putting the most money we got an entire
ocean of water separate that's your
threat that's your problem bro make your
marriage work let me try like try to fix
my marriage here America's already
trying to almost be divided let me keep
my husband and wife together we're
divorced no we have a we have a million
deaths to overdose in the past 20 years
we have 130 to 50,000 people dying a
year to overdose we have veterans living
under bridges cuz they can't get mental
health assistance we have hom people the
country is a mess forget the
division for a second we have real
issues that exists outside of my
sentiment versus my neighbors you just
nailed why America first and I get that
but here take it even one more layer
keep than just being able to ask a
question the even deeper question is why
the am I having to ask this
question who are these people that are
are running this question you know what
the answer is to that corporations no
the easy answer to it is because most
people think the way you think and I
love how you're just straight up like
you said I just want to come and have
the conversation you're talking about
the the Twitter spaces I did right after
the santis right that's the one you're
talking about I got it so most yeah most
people are like dude I don't want to
freaking have all these fights over poot
can I just talk about the game like guys
what do you think you think Chief you
think this game is set up and the Super
Bowl is going to be all about Taylor
Swift because Taylor swi Chiefs are
going to win it let's have most people
want to have that conversation most
people want to say do you think Mahomes
is better than Tom Brady if he wins this
this is four and six is he better than
is the conversation already there should
we already start debating this that's
what most people don't want to have
conversation I just want to know if you
guys want to be Crow generically Frozen
like like like I'm even further than I
wish this wasn't the case but it is it
is important but the point but the point
to to say to what you're saying the
point is you know the fact that why did
it even get to the point of asking this
question and why didn't we already know
because we've been brainwashed into not
asking these questions through our
educational system and the teachers and
all that stuff every 13 Professor on the
left one is on the right 98% of I told
this to Bill Mah he says that's a big
problem 98% of English teachers in high
school donate to the left 2% give to the
right
97% of science teachers give to the left
only three give to the right and 87% of
Math teachers give to the left 1% is
that new because that's the other thing
too nowadays is like how much of this is
like new stuff versus how much of this
is is just a further elevation of
discussion of stuff that's been
happening like for example like
establishment bro there's a movie called
1984 like all of that stuff we this has
been 40 years in the making like like
have teacher teachers have always been
liberal liberalism is a is a portion of
not sorry you're right not always but
but as of the right 40 plus years have
been progressed it's just not this
extreme and unions have never been this
intentional in using these blocks as
voting blocks like the other day who
said the other day they're voting for
they endorse Biden which Union was it
United autow workers Rob is that what it
was oh it's over because the United Auto
Workers dude the power of what unions
are doing nowadays those are voting
blocks there's a lot of different things
that's going on some of it hasn't
changed some of it has but the simple
thing is access to social media is
getting us to get more connected and ask
the questions we've not asked before
yeah I agree and then and my going to
the member because you said that the
presidency is one thing but the local if
you think just look at the worst blues
uh LA right Chicago's horrible New York
forget it the homeless I mean not the
homeless the illegals that they are
bringing in that the mayor was like yeah
Adam's like come in they're not only
in the street they're banging
on people's houses and asking for money
so again they're not all brought in by
by New York by the way some are some are
shipped there as as a a lesson to be not
even lesson but yeah as a lesson AKA if
you guys want to talk to talk start
taking some of these people like when
they did to Martha's Vineyard well my
thing is Mike how like these places like
LA and Nome and all the why do people
keep voting for these people that's the
CU because at the end of the day that's
it I get it you're a you're you're the
blue state but bro they tried to uh
recall Nome well Larry aler didn't have
a chance but it's like the people it
comes down to Mike your attitude that
sentiment that that attitude bro people
have to take a stand it's like when is
enough going to be enough and people are
going to just sit there and complain
look what they're doing in uh France
those farmers and they're filling
up tractors with manure and going to
that's what I'm talking about it's th
this we could do this all day but I love
that you were like it's local these the
Big Wigs they're going to do what
they're going to do the local people if
you keep voting for people that are
Nome is bro just look at what
California is and that guy's going to
try to run for presidency and people
will vote for Mike but Mikey
people will vote for that guy cuz he's
not guy for Nome oh yeah Nome would
would be a great freaking thing for the
uh he he's on the list right he's on the
he's on the top five by the way Vegas
odds right now number three is Michelle
Obama that oh Michelle yeah Michelle
with him Michelle and him okay okay this
is an interesting thing can I ask you a
couple odd questions all right all
right the mo even going even more like
local than just your city like go to
yourself right social media has been a
great weapon for conversation but it's
also been an incredible incredibly
weird weapon for misinformation and I
think one of the greatest Amos we had
for our personal weapon of change has
been uh fact has been has been
information if you come to the table
with information you can make informed
decisions and have informed
conversations unfortunately nowadays
finding information that that is deemed
uh or that you deem to be good
information has I don't think it's ever
been harder I I just think there's so
much out there and even to I rely
on this engine or that engine is is it's
you got to do a or have a researcher
that's helping you disseminate and
figure out what information is actually
true right
um do you think that Michelle Obama's a
man like how far like how far do you how
far are you willing to like go on these
like on this like swinging type
because like like what swinging not that
type you said it not that typ you said
swinging I'm like where's it going
because because like dude like I just
it it angers me and I think I think it
also does a disservice to people who are
asking the right questions on the
anti-establishment side when there is a
heavy representation of this just pure
stupidity I mean I mean dude like like
like there's a person on Twitter I'm not
going to say their name but they know
who they are that tweets all day about
Big Mike AKA Michelle Obama being a man
this person could be using their voice
you don't convert like that oh he's oh
he's converted how do you mean how do no
no but you don't you don't persuade like
that you don't you don't persued by like
for example Nome by the way this account
is number two or number three most
engaged accounts on Twitter oh okay
and they're big mic that's all they're
saying but but here's the point but but
here's the point though after Elon and
Tate yeah the point is what what's your
outcome is your outcome to be a echo
chamber and have those people come and
find you you and retweet your stuff yeah
that works I mean there's a guy Jackson
uh on Twitter what's his last name
Jackson I think Jackson hle right by the
way during uh what happened with Israel
Gaza he is the stuff some of the stuff
he tweets I mean it's pretty pretty
extreme stuff so it just
seemed when you talk about the stuff
just know that I'm I'm already seeing it
all cuz I'm on chronically online not a
fan of that he he just he just it just
so inauthentic who's this the the Han
because because let me let me explain
this one to you the tweets would be
these like really nasty tweets about
what was going on in Gaza and and by the
way bring the awareness that's so
important but it would be like the the
atrocity in Gaza must stop now subscribe
to my premium for only $3 and I don't
know why it just always is like I'm not
saying I don't know why it just always
are you building awareness are you
building awareness or are you trying to
build a subscribership like that that is
that immediate not just a subscribership
on on on X where you continue to put
good information out there but that just
brings you money a subscription but but
the the risk of freedom of speech is
you're can to have both types of people
and you have to be okay with it right
you just have to know like okay the
moment you have an after hours Club
where you serve alcohol what's going to
come with it let's actually go through
drugs fight sexy drugs knowers
knows that saud's about to be having how
crazy is that czy is that 74 years and
they passed a repealed their alcohol ban
but but the point what's the point here
the point is when you when you open it
up like you ever been at a club and
somebody's overdosing yeah if you're in
the club business if you're in the club
business that comes with the territory
yep you ever been in a club a guy comes
up with like a 100 pills you know hey 25
bucks 25 bucks okay great that comes
with the business you're in the business
of freedom speech speech is you're going
to have the Jacksons and you're going to
have the other side they're going to do
that for me again it goes back to what
you're solving for everything you have
to start off with that question remember
when he asked me he said what can't we
can't go back to that what am I solving
for I'm not solving for uh uh uh just
followership or just doing this and
doing that do you know how many people
get pissed that me and Chris Cuomo have
a
relationship I'm not I'm him and I talk
today for 45 minutes do you know how
many people get upset that him and I
talk they get so upset like why would
you talk to that guy that guy was a CNN
number one show he was the one that told
people vaccine and he was decent when
his basement and totally get it okay
guess what I like what I'm solving for
is not an echo chamber I like talking to
people right and push and let's go and
oh shoot there's a leak there well then
let me go do a little bit more research
oh that's a good question right there
let me go do this I like thater I'm not
solving
for just being right I'm solving for a
great conversation but there's a lot of
people as as you just said that are
doing that just for ego for likes for
comments for engagement for subscriber
Bas how do you how do you how do you
separate how do you separate the two
because because for us to all sit here
especi like for you guys to sit here and
say like oh I'm able to weed out this
person I'm able to weed out that person
not everybody's able to do that and I
understand
like that is that is the greatest
responsibility of fre of the freedom of
speech
rule that we have is that people have a
responsibility to be
like this person is not trustworthy this
is not is this not authentic person I
don't want to hear what they're saying
and and then tune them out but some
people can't do that the market the the
market nowadays is is going to expose
anybody that's being inauthentic like
even social media how many people have
you seen blow up on YouTube and then die
off wait a minute what happened to that
guy do you remember that one guy yeah
what do have not seen him for this what
happened to her what happened to this
this Market is very brutal the moment
you're no longer being straight up and
honest and it's just the market will
expose you in a heartbeat that's how
competition works but no for us we're
solving for that and and by the way this
this this this concept of power versus
Force the book you know the whole power
versus for you ever heard of power
versus for you would love this book
power versus Force I think it's
something Schwarz if you can pull it up
yeah and and can you it's Hawkins yeah
it's Hawkins I always say Schwarz go
back to it go back to the previous page
just go to images yeah just go to images
okay when you think about this uh type
in chart next to power verse no take the
book out if you just take out book there
so go to the middle one go to the one to
the right of that what to the right of
that there you go zoom in a little bit
into that so watch this from the lowest
level of Consciousness to the highest
level look at the third chart third not
God you life shame is the lowest level
lowest level of Consciousness in life is
to be ashamed it's the worst place to be
ashamed then it's guilt CU you keep
reliving the mistake you made it was my
fault it's all my fault apathy right you
know grief regret constantly in that
place fear produces anxiety Panic right
desire you're addicted to food drugs
alcohol sex all this stuff anger rage
hate aggression Pride it's about me I
can't be wrong d d and then first step
is what courage courage the courage to
be wrong the courage to have the
discussion right and even go to
neutrality I'm will to entertain both
sides you're willing to talk you're
optimistic acceptance forg I think
that's where I think that's where I I
think I'm in that three in that two
which one acceptance or willingness no
and the neutrality willingness
definitely not El Super elevated but but
but check this out even even being
neutrality though right this if you look
at this chart this also represents a
community and a country right
America is not above it right now
America's below it right now is this the
pride
flag so funny how the did that
happen they stole it from turn into they
stole of Consciousness oh my God sorry
so but but the point is when you think
about like where when you think about
where we are as a country okay uh the
country's level of Consciousness right
now is definitely not a neutrality I'd
say 150 I say I think that's the number
I think you're right I think that's
where it's honestly I I was going to say
we're really gay
because on it America gayer than it's
ever been we're somewhere between 150
and 175 yeah well according to gen Z
they're now a third third a third Iden
gender queer what is it gend queer yeah
so that's that's that's uh anyways uh
look I I I'm going to go check on these
two kids but Mike this has been a
fantastic conversation what I love is
the fact that how you're just you know
you know going through your own phase
and you're asking the questions to get
to a point and most importantly although
you wish that you don't want to wish
this upon people honestly you don't want
to wish for you to go through those
three incidents violent crime in
California to get to this conclusion to
realize policies in California is not
working because unfortunately there's
other people like yeah I don't believe
it he's just saying this okay great and
then they're going to go through right
and then they're going to like dude this
is really actually happening but that's
just and quickly that's just one that's
one of the things and like we didn't
even really get into we didn't even talk
about AB substance abuse or any of the
book or anything like that but like
quickly for anybody watching this who's
going through anything like that
violence against them mental anguish
which I've spent a good chunk of my life
in uh uh substance abuse every single
one of the the horrible things that you
read about in the book that I've been
through every time I was a ashamed every
time I was embarrassed every time I was
guilty of something every time I upset
my mother my probation officer all led
me to this table today every single one
of those things every single one of
those days that I woke up and I didn't
want to wake up every single one of
those days where I didn't think I was
going to be able to put one foot in
front of the other because I I was too
tired or exhausted or or not in the
right mind to do so led me to where I am
today so for people watching this right
now who are having a tough time who are
going through stuff in their own lives
who are somewhere low on that chart and
and waiting for a chance to to to be
better and to show people and to impress
people your days comeing just keep going
my man by the way Rob that's the can you
go can you have uh Malik can you show
that the book on the screen oh no no
because Malik controls the screen not
Rob and and also Rob if you can put the
link in the chat please and also in the
description as well as in the comment
section uh order the book The Fifth
vital uh incredible uh story of 180
going from where you were at to where
you are today I applaud you for that and
I appreciate you for coming down and
having this conversation and now listen
when you're in the moment and you're
going through some of the stories it's
like sensitive stuff while you're going
through nobody wants to have those
conversations but you were Class Act
about it you took the questions we went
through it um and aside from that gang
again go click on the link place the
order order the book Mike I'm sure we'll
do something in the future again love
too thank you so much you look like you
want to say something do you want to say
I just want to say all you guys and
that's it I just God connect with vin on
man and we have a podcast tomorrow
morning tomorrow 9:00 a.m. we got home I
don't know how you guys I don't know how
they told me 9:00 a.m. I was like
dude I said I got this job so I didn't
have we're going south beach after this
buddy let's go he's oh I'll go I got to
go back anyways thank you guys honestly
thank you br God bless you baby take
care everybody we'll see you in the
morning bye- bye
bye-bye